of of of of their daughter lib but that
was the issue it was the handling of the
story that then unfolded because they'
let it be known that she supported it
she was it was basally put around she
given it their B her blessing um and
then the BBC reported no that's not what
happened she wasn't asked and there was
a sort of big um tussle between the be
and the sussex's team and then um the
Sussex has issued legal proceedings and
um went to the palace and said well you
you'll back up our version of events at
which point there was a resigning
silence um
because we don't know precisely who said
what to whom but this idea that the
queen had given her blessing clearly did
not sit with the palace and the queen
doesn't she loves Harry she loves lilb
but that that's unchanged U but no one
um rearranges the Queen's words if you
like